uh what do you think is the meaning of
life
this whole thing the existence the the
the all the hurried things we do on this
planet
what do you think is the meaning of it
all yeah well you know i think we're all
really bad at it
life or finding meaning or both yeah we
get caught up in in in the it's easy to
get easier to do the stuff that's
immediate and not through the stuff it's
not immediate
um so the big picture
yeah
yeah do you have a sense of what that
big picture is like why you ever look up
to the stars and ask why the hell are we
here
you know my my
my my atheism tells me it's just random
but you know i want to understand the
the way random
in and that's what i talk about in this
book how order comes from disorder yeah
um
[Music]
but it kind of sprung up like most of
the whole thing is random but this
little
pocket of complexity they would call
earth
that like why the hell does that happen
and and what we don't know
is how common that
pop those pockets of complexity are or
how often
um because they may not last
forever
which is uh more exciting slash sad to
you if we're alone or if there's
infinite number of oh i i think i think
it's impossible for me to believe that
we're alone
um
that would just be too horrible too
cruel
it could be like the sad thing it could
be like a graveyard of intelligent
civilizations oh everywhere yeah that
might be the most likely outcome
and for us too yeah exactly yeah and all
of this will be forgotten yeah
including all the robots you build
everything forgotten
well on average
everyone has been forgotten in history
yeah right
yeah most people are not remembered
beyond a generation or two
um
i mean yeah well not just on average
basically
very close to 100 percent of people
who've ever lived or forgotten yeah i
mean
no longer i don't know anyone alive who
remembers my great grandparents because
we didn't meet them
so
still this fun this uh
this uh life is pretty fun somehow yeah
even the
immense absurdity and uh at times
meaninglessness of it all it's pretty
fun and one of the for me one of the
most fun things is
robots and i've looked up to your work
i've looked up to you for a long time
that's right
ron it it's it's an honor that uh
you would spend your valuable time with
me today talking it was an amazing
conversation thank you so much for being
here well thanks phil thanks for talking
with me i've enjoyed it
you